[Music]
on this Sunday night Halloween
heartbreak and morning in Seoul as more
families find out the worst news there's
so many people first-hand accounts of a
celebration that turned into a stampede
Brazil's polarizing presidential runoff
now in the hands of Voters emotions run
high on Election Day
ER wait times costing lives these are
people who are dying or waiting to be
assessed to see what care they need
addressing the health human resource
crisis
and sugar high no not a trick at the
cash register why Halloween treats now
cost more
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
there is deep grief in South Korea
tonight residents there are now waking
up on a Monday morning to a national
period of mourning
at least 154 people are now confirmed
dead after a crowd surge in a popular
area of Seoul on a busy Saturday night
young party goers some still in their
teens have been out celebrating
Halloween but the crowd quickly grew out
of control
waves are coming in from both sides and
more people felt and then I lost my
friend
lives changed in an instant parents
waited in agony to find out if their
children were among the dead most were
young women 20 of the victims were
foreign Nationals one Canadian was
injured in the chaos Dan Spector has our
top story tonight on a nation searching
for answers but before we begin a
warning some of the images here are
quite graphic
it was supposed to be an exuberant
Halloween bash in seoul's main nightlife
District but as tens of thousands packed
in to join the party itaewon became a
scene of true horror dozens of mostly
young people killed crushed to death or
suffocated authorities saying 80 percent
were in their 20s or 30s there's so many
people and I'd like turn around and I
told the crowd you can't come this way
people are dying panicked people trapped
in the neighborhood's narrow alleys
tried to claw their way up to get out
making matters worse First Responders
had to battle through the same crowds
just to get in some revelers were left
to try to save their friends lives
perform CPR in the streets others were
oblivious the music was too loud but we
heard someone screaming and then someone
from around they said like there is
people dying there Korean officials are
investigating how it unfolded crowd
control experts point to this being the
country's first big Halloween party
after years of strict coveted
restrictions there's a lot more people
in places of public assembly than before
and fewer trained staff to care for the
safety Sunday Seoul streets were
littered with grim evidence of the
trauma some paying tribute to those who
lost their lives South Korea's president
touring the scene expressing condolences
and saying it never should have happened
it always starts with what is the area
what are the approach routes uh what is
the safe holding capacity and if it
starts to exceed that how do we prevent
a crush developing world leaders
including prime minister Trudeau
extending sympathies
at this Korean Church in Ottawa
parishioners praying for the victims
there are more than 200 000 Korean
Canadians many familiar with where the
chaos unfolded along with their sorrow
anger there should have been a better
crowd control because people knew that
this was going to be the crowded area so
many Canadians among those around the
world wondering how something like this
can happen and how to make sure nothing
like it ever happens again the inspector
Global News Ottawa
people travel to Seoul from all over the
world to celebrate Halloween in it
Taiwan the district is hugely popular
with locals and tourists known for its
nightlife and teeming with borrowers and
trendy restaurants it's one of seoul's
busiest areas Seoul itself is a massive
city with a population of nearly 10
million people the City's population
density is almost twice that of New York
frantic rescue efforts are ongoing in
Western India after a suspension bridge
collapsed killing at least 81 people
as many as 400 people were on the bridge
at the time when they plunged into the
river below footage shows survivors
clinging to ropes as night fell others
swimming and scrambling to safety there
are calls for an immediate investigation
into the collapse the 230 meter Bridge
is a huge tourist attraction it was
built over a hundred years ago but only
just reopened after undergoing repairs
at least a hundred people were killed
after two car bombs struck a busy market
and somalia's capital Mogadishu the
first bomb hit the Ministry of Education
building on Saturday and then the second
went off as ambulances arrived at the
scene no group has claimed
responsibility but somalia's President
says the al-Qaeda linked al-shabab
Terror groups to blame hundreds of
people were injured and the number of
dead is also expected to rise to the war
in Ukraine now Russia has pulled out of
the U.N brokered deal that ensured grain
exports could leave Ukraine's ports
foreign
's president vlodimir zielinski accused
Russia of deliberately creating Global
famine and called their decision
predictable Moscow says the move was in
response to a recent drone strike on its
Black Sea Fleet in Crimea blaming it on
Ukraine hundreds of ships are now
stranded unable to continue their
passage the U.N says it will attempt to
revive the deal
to breaking news now Brazil has a new
leader following what's been a bitterly
contested election to pick the country's
next president according to the latest
polls former president Louis anacia Lula
de Silva has won the race to nine
far-right incumbent jair bolsonaro a
second term as Mike Armstrong reports
the election was extremely tense and
serves as a referendum on two very
different Visions for Brazil's future
it is one of the biggest countries in
the world by population and voting is
compulsory when Brazilians go to the
polls it's a lot of people about 156
million were eligible to punch their
choice for president into the country's
electronic voting machines
the Amazon it meant moving voting
machines in by boat
she says there's no roads so they have
to follow the river so no one's left out
Brazil had more than 470 thousand
polling stations spread all throughout
the country
it also had voters around the globe
these are expats casting ballots in
Paris Sunday this is Lisbon in Portugal
and this is Montreal where about 8 000
passed through the process for this
runoff election took about an hour
that's considerably less than the four
to six hours the first round voting took
in Montreal just four weeks ago I know
it's a lot but it's very important to me
to vote well that electronic voting
system meant there wasn't prolonged
suspense
within less than three hours of the
polls closing former president Luis
Ignacio Lula de Silva had built up an
insurmountable lead albeit razor thin
it'll be just over one percent commonly
known as Lula he returns to the
presidency a position he held from 2003
to 2010.
after a bitter campaign between two
polarizing figures there is work ahead
political analyst Ricardo Ishmael says
the first thing the new president will
have to do is calm the country the mood
right now he says is too tense
a big question will be how the defeated
candidate reacts far-right populist jair
bolsonaro has said he could only lose if
the election was stolen observers say he
may borrow from the Donald Trump
Playbook denying the legitimacy of the
vote to keep his base motivated to stay
the face of the opposition and to
prepare a comeback of some kind
when it comes from Global News Montreal
to another hotly contested battle the
U.S midterms America's biggest
intelligence agencies are warning of
threats against politicians and polling
sites as election day is just days away
now these are the first midterms since
former president Donald Trump polarized
parts of the country claiming the 2020
election was stolen from him and the new
warnings come after the hammer attack
injuring the husband of U.S House
speaker Nancy Pelosi Jennifer Johnson
has more
your vote will make a difference with
just over a week till the U.S midterm
elections Democrats are bringing out the
big guns to energize their base former
president Barack Obama is crisscrossing
the country to help Democrats keep
control of Congress and win
gubernatorial races but the campaign
Trail has become treacherous territory
as threats against politicians rise
dramatically this habit of
saying the worst about other people
demonizing people
that creates a dangerous climate the FBI
and Department of Homeland Security have
issued a new joint intelligence bulletin
warning of elevated threats against
politicians poll workers election
officials and targets including
political rallies and voting sites the
intelligence units of these departments
have got to kick it into high gear it's
a challenge like never before the
warning comes after the brutal attack
against house Speaker Nancy Pelosi's
husband in their San Francisco home
Pelosi has broken her silence writing
our children our grandchildren and I are
heartbroken and traumatized by the
life-threatening attack but it's not
just the Pelosi's last week a
Pennsylvania man pleaded guilty to
threatening to kill California
Congressman Eric swalwell election
workers are also being targeted
including Leslie Hoffman in Arizona who
quit her job after threats following the
2020 election there was stuff on
Facebook a lot of emails things like we
we have you now we have proof better
watch your back you should be hung in
Most states early voting has already
begun U.S President Joe Biden is among
20 million people to have cast ballots
but tensions are high armed and masked
so-called pole monitors have been seen
in Phoenix patrolling ballot drop-off
boxes it is unacceptable Behavior it's
undemocratic and we all need to work
together to ensure that this is a safe
and secure election a federal judge has
ruled the armed enforcers of a
constitutional right to be there while
acknowledging their actions raise
serious concerns for many Americans on
edge this election can't come soon
enough
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
and we're learning more about the
Canadian suspect accused of attacking
Paul Pelosi 42-year-old David depap
carried zip ties as he broke into the
couple's home on Friday night depop was
born in Canada and he grew up in Powell
River British Columbia Police say the
attack wasn't random and said to Pap
supported several conspiracy theories in
online posts to Pap will be charged on
Monday he's been arrested on suspicion
of attempted murder elder abuse and
burglary
coming up doctors Sound the Alarm about
life-threatening ER wait times
[Music]
our country's Health Care crisis appears
to be hitting a breaking point that
holds dangerous consequences for
Canadians seeking medical help you or
someone you know has likely waited an
unusually long time inside an emergency
room to get desperately needed care as
Heather York's West reports that amount
of time has not only put people at risk
it's already left some to die
back in June Kim Hodgson cramp's
daughter became incredibly sick a
temperature of 105 her breathing like I
watched her whole body work with every
breath
I was terrified as a parent six-year-old
Kavanaugh was first treated at an
Edmonton Community Health Center and
while an ambulance was then called to
bring her to the stullery Children's
Hospital it would take 33 hours before
it got there by the time we got to
stallery
um
the paramedics spoke with emergency and
they put us right into the waiting room
with everybody else and it was another
six to eight hours before we got a room
lengthy wait times for emergency care
have become all too familiar right
across the country but beyond being
frustrating those wait times are now
costing lives last weekend Montreal area
physician Dr sebasti Moran shared this
tragedy online I ended my night on a
patient who died in front of me with a
ruptured thoracic aorta this same
patient had waited 16 hours yesterday in
another hospital without being seen for
his pain he left I couldn't do anything
he died within minutes of his arrival
it's up to patients to tell their
individual stories but I can you know
share that a very similar situation with
different problems is happening on
average once a month in this province
that I'm aware of according to Dr Warren
thirsk since May in Alberta alone seven
patients have died waiting for emergency
care these are people who are dying
while we waiting to be assessed to see
what care they need I think that this
will continue to be a problem in
Canadian health care until we address
the health human resource crisis that
we're faced with right now it's why the
president of the Canadian Medical
Association says the country's 13
provincial and territorial Health
Systems need to start working together
to find Solutions fast we all know that
there's a crisis what we're waiting for
is action
a Country-Wide Health crisis in need of
critical care Heather York's West Global
News Calgary
Alberta's Premier Danielle Smith
announced her government is exploring
ways to block schools from implementing
mask mandates in a statement on Saturday
Smith claims that masking has had
detrimental effects on children's mental
health and education and that they must
turn the page on an extremely difficult
time her reaction follows a judge's
decision to call February's lifting of
mass mandates unreasonable because it
was decided by cabinet and not Alberta's
chief medical officer Smith says her
government will examine appealing that
ruling
education workers in Ontario could be
hitting the picket lines this Friday the
Canadian Union of public employees also
known as QP which represents 55 000
education workers has served the Ontario
government a formal strike notice
negotiations between the union and the
province are scheduled to resume on
Tuesday mediation talks broke down with
both sides unable to reach an agreement
on wages Two school boards in Ontario
have already said they will close
schools of Education workers go on a
full strike
[Music]
I had the creepy rise and the cost of
candy ahead of Hallows Eve
if all the costumes and pumpkins and in
my case very giddy kids have include you
in yet Halloween is tomorrow and if you
haven't gotten your candy yet beware
because before the kids go door to door
you might want to go Supermarket to
supermarket looking for a bargain as
Zach power reports the cost of candy is
soaring
it's the day before these familiar words
Shoppers spent Sunday morning flocking
from store to store looking for treats
and not tricks for their wallet I've
noticed the price gone up a little bit
um and not much left in stores this time
of year I don't know every year it goes
up a little bit more last year we I
bought like a whole big box of uh like
all those candies but but this year
actually I just bought those two like
six dollars two for six dollars uh yeah
I've noticed it's gone up some this year
but 10 10 or 15 percent and the Shoppers
are right in their report Dalhousie
University notes that the price has gone
up 13 making it the largest increase to
date a recent study finds that Canadians
are spending more on treats than what
they would have last year but those
numbers are still shy of pre-pandemic
sales I've been kind of buying like the
party packs instead of like individually
I guess so that's all that I've really
noticed usually I give two or three
things out but uh this time I'm just
trying to give them one for many
regardless of the price the spirit of
Halloween is still alive and well and
many kids won't go home with empty
pillowcases this year when they do come
to my house they've got to climb a large
driveway so they get they get a lot of
treats we're gonna try to keep as much
candy going as we can of course and so I
am expecting quite a bit of kids so
that's why I'm just stocking up and
buying more candy because it's kind of
unknown Zach power Global News St John
Okay Candy aside this could be actually
scary for those who love binge watching
some bad news the world's biggest
streaming service Netflix is officially
launching commercial breaks into some of
your favorite movies and TV shows as
inflation Source programming costs are
rising so Netflix and other streaming
services like Disney plus and Amazon
Prime are of course looking to grow
their revenue streams and to do that
Netflix announced it will officially
launch a cheaper basic plan from
November 4th that includes ad breaks and
even more expensive plan without ads
there will be an average of four to five
minutes of ads for each hour
no
food with friends next how London's
newcomers are getting the support they
need over lunch
[Music]
moving to a different country is no easy
task it's uprooting your entire life and
culture to go somewhere where you don't
know a lot of people and for Asylum
Seekers they might arrive with little to
nothing at all now try doing all that in
one of Europe's most expensive places to
live as Crystal gemancing Reports that's
why a London food bank is bringing
newcomers together to eat and to build
Connections in the face of uncertainty
foreign
so many moms can whip up a meal while
juggling multiple conversations
especially for my country in Syria a
chicken shawarma the mother of four
smiles and laughs easily clearly
relishing and her role as chef at Dad's
house
take this one please
if and this one uh spicy one spicy yeah
jamana came to London in 2009.
I'm live in Sweden before five years I
feel in that house is my family everyone
here helped me if I need anything
a new extended family is what many have
found here Thai Japanese
um black British who else have we got oh
Moroccan
Algerian how many is that that's a few
the meal they share becomes the bond
they talk relax and take food off the
shelf if they need inflation in
September hit 10.1 percent here the cost
of living aside life in London can be
especially hard for those new to the
country there's the culture and for some
uncertainty over how welcome you are we
are
these friends were hesitant to say they
crossed the English Channel hostilities
exist about the record number of people
arriving in small boats from France many
Asylum Seekers according to the refugee
Council live on the equivalent of eight
Canadian dollars a day and they're not
allowed to work while their claim is
being processed it's why twice a week
dad's house invites people to share a
hot home-cooked meal but everyone has to
eat together I feel this safe now we try
and
to
do like normally and that is recently
included protesting at the Iranian
Embassy in London in support of women's
rights
Maybe This Time It's For Revolution new
freedoms and new Connections in the face
of daily struggles but here
time is a commodity worth its weight in
gold
Crystal commencing Global News London
that smile is everything and that's
global national for this Sunday night
I'm Farah Nasser and on behalf of our
whole crew I want to thank you so much
for spending part of your Sunday evening
with us we're going to leave you tonight
with what the NHL is calling costume of
the year a video showing five-year-old
Ontario Oilers fan Easton oding is going
viral for his hockey themed Halloween
get-up you really can't beat a
custom-made Zamboni until next time take
care of yourselves and each other good
night
[Music]
thank you
foreign